إنها رحلة مدتها ثلاث ساعات من
منزل شكيلا إلى وسط كابول ،
لكن كل صباح تقوم
هي ونساء أخريات بهذه المسيرة
بدافع
الحاجة إلى إطعام أطفالهن
وجهتهم هي هذا المخبز
واحد من العديد من المخبز في جميع أنحاء العاصمة حيث
تجلس حشود من النساء الآن بصبر  كل
يوم
يأملون بهدوء في الحصول على الصدقات ،
لذلك كانت جميع النساء
يضغطن على قطع من الورق بأرقام
هواتفهن في أيدينا ، ويأملن بشدة أنه ربما يمكننا مساعدتهن ، تخبرنا شيكيلا في يوم جيد أنهن
قد يحصلن على قطعتين أو ثلاث قطع من الخبز
كل
لقمة إذا كنت تفعل هذا قبل عام أو
أن الوضع أصبح أسوأ في العام الماضي
، لا يوجد عمل هذا العام تقول إن
زوجي لديه عربة ولكنه الآن يكسب فقط
30 إلى 40 سنتًا في اليوم
بعد عام واحد من تولي طالبان السلطة
أفغانستان معزولة وفقر بشكل متزايد
معزول إلى حد كبير عن النظام المصرفي العالمي
والمساعدات الخارجية التي كانت تمول في السابق
ما يقرب من 80 في المائة من ميزانية هذا البلد ،
فهي أيضًا غير ملائمة.  شيء واحد أكثر أمانًا بشكل ثابت
تمكن طالبان من
تحسينه هو الأمن
خارج متاجر مطار كابول مفتوحة
والشوارع هادئة
بعيدة كل البعد عن المشاهد الفوضوية التي
شهدناها في الصيف
الماضي ، أخبرني بتغطية إيماني
لكنه لا يريد التعليق
[  موسيقى]
ابقوا خلفه وراءه
يخشى الكثيرون على حياتهم
أن يعيد طالبان البلاد إلى
العصور الوسطى
بالنسبة لهؤلاء الفتيات
التي تحققت مخاوفهن بعد عام واحد فقط من
تخرجهن ، وأعلن حزب طالبان
حظرًا فعليًا على هؤلاء الفتيات.  التعليم الثانوي للفتيات
بعد الصف السادس
الآن لديهم طرق مرتجلة
لتحدي حظر إنشاء مدارس غير رسمية
حيث يكملون دراستهم.
قوية وهذه الأشياء لا يمكن أن تجلب
عماتي وأحلامي وما
أريد أن أفعله هل تشعر بالخوف من أي وقت مضى نعم
إنه خطر كبير بالنسبة لنا أننا نفعل ذلك نحن
لا نغطي  وجه ونحن ندرس
دروسنا ، أنت شجاع جدًا ، نعم أعرف أن
تعليم الفتيات هو أحد الأسباب الرئيسية
لعدم اعتراف أي دولة في العالم حتى الآن
بحكومة طالبان.
عودة الفتيات إلى المدرسة
من منظور الحكومة ،
هناك مجموعة من القضايا التي
أدت إلى
التعليق المؤقت للمدارس الثانوية
، أهم
جزء من هذا هو أن سياسة
الحكومة الأفغانية
هي التعليم من أجل  جميع مواطني
أفغانستان ومع ذلك جميع مواطني
أفغانستان غير قادرين حاليًا على
الحصول على التعليم ما هو التعطيل
يبدو أن
الجهات الفاعلة الدولية للأسف تعمل على
تسليح قضية التعليم بدلاً من
التقدم والتفاعل بشكل إيجابي ،
فهم يحاولون إيجاد
مبررات أخلاقية للبعض.  لسياسات العقوبات اللاإنسانية
التي تؤدي إلى
العقاب الجماعي للجماعة
يا شعب أفغانستان ، هل تريد أن ترى
الفتيات يذهبن إلى المدرسة مرة أخرى ،
فإن سياسة حكومة
أفغانستان واضحة جدًا وهي
التعليم لجميع مواطني
أفغانستان ، تقول طالبان إنها تريد أن
ترى علاقات سلمية وإيجابية مع
جميع البلدان بما في ذلك الولايات المتحدة
لكن هذه الآفاق
تضاءلت بشكل كبير عندما قُتل رئيس القاعدة
إيمان الظواهري
في غارة أمريكية بطائرة بدون طيار في فيلا في وسط مدينة
كابول قبل أكثر من أسبوعين بقليل ، لقد
أوضحنا أن
حكومة أفغانستان لم تكن على دراية
بالأمر.  وصول السيد الظواهري أو وجوده
في
كابول
حتى الآن لم نتمكن من
إثبات حقيقة أن
السيد الظواهري كان
حاضرًا بالفعل في الكأس ليس مخيفًا بدرجة أكبر على
الرغم من أن فكرة أنك
تدعي أنه من المحتمل أن
كان زعيم القاعدة هنا في وسط
المدينة ولم تكن تعرف عنه
مرة أخرى ، فنحن نجادل في فكرة أنه
كان حاضرًا هنا ،
ولكن حتى لو كان من
هذه الأنواع  من الحوادث تحدث
في كل مكان في العالم
لكنها في الحقيقة لا أقصد كيف يمكن
للولايات المتحدة أن تثق
في قيادة طالبان رغم
أنها تظل وفية لوعدها بأنها
لن تسمح بمنح ملاذ
للجماعات الإرهابية
أه إذا نظرنا إلى الدوحة  الاتفاق على
المواد
التي تحدد
التزامات حكومة أفغانستان
كلها قد تم الوفاء بها وإذا
نظرنا إلى الالتزامات التي تعهدت بها
الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية للأسف
فهي لم تف بمقالة واحدة
ولكننا نأمل ونحن  الاستمرار في
حث الولايات المتحدة على الالتزام بهذا
الاتفاق ،
إنه موقف وقح يعقد
الجهود لإلغاء تجميد التمويل لمساعدة
الشعب الأفغاني
الذي يظل الملايين منهم
جائعين ويعتمدون على لطف الغرباء
كلاريسا وارد سي إن إن
كابول.